[Music]
you recently posted a lesson of the day
and your lesson of the day was don't
search for Eric Stonestreet nude now
then you put up this picture this what
you found
picture I was gonna stay hairy until you
get to this yeah no there's more of that
picture that I didn't include on my
Instagram you see the whole thing
you're welcome everyone yeah there you
see the whole thing right Wow okay so I
maybe that's what cost you maybe she
went on Google and you were in the
bathroom yeah
I posted that while we were working on
the show and people saw it in and one
guy was like dude that takes a lot of
courage for you to post it because that
that like it it's a really good
Photoshop job people are gonna actually
think that she wouldn't like I never
thought about that actually considered
that that was that was the case that
would you ever vote would you ever
Google yourself make now I don't Google
myself at all I don't want to know what
people think I don't know why it's a
good time I had a little free time
before I came over here Google what did
you google Conan O'Brien O'Brien nude
can we show them what
[Applause]
wait there's that looks like I have a
deformed look at it what is that oh
that's it's like a squid yeah it's like
silly putty that's my hand what is it oh
my gosh and they're going oh yeah it's
it's well Andy I hate to break it to you
but I will do you naked too oh really
I'm curious about this
[Applause]